PROFESSOR: Any questions before
we push bravely onward?
OK if there's no question
on any of this I shall
clean off the board.
And the last thing I wanted to
do in connection with thermal
expansion is to examine how the
macroscopic linear thermal
expansion coefficient relates to
the nature of the potential
minimum between--
in the attraction between--
neighboring atoms.
So let me suppose we have a
pair of atoms separated by
some distance, d, and there is
a cohesive force between them
or else the material would
not be in a solid state.
And the nature of
the potential--
and I'm going to call
the distance
between the atoms, x--
and this is going to
be the energy.
And I'm measuring now
relative to--
let me call this d as I did over
here-- so the energy as a
function of d is going to
consist of a very short range,
repulsive interaction, that
rises very, very rapidly when
you attempt to squeeze the atoms
any closer than a fairly
small value.
And then there'll be some
sort of cohesive energy.
And everybody loves to model
ionic compounds because in an
ionic compound this cohesive
force would be purely a
Coulombic force that would be,
in rationalized MKS units, 1
over 4 pi epsilon zero times the
product of the charges and
divided by the distance
between them.
Taking those two potentials
together, and you've all seen
this many times before, there
is a minimum in the energy.
And then absolute zero--
that is the separation
at which this
atom pair would sit--
and this would be the binding
energy of that ionic pair.
If you carry this through to get
the entire energy of the
crystal, you find that the
energy of the crystal goes as
1 minus 1 over--
haven't introduced
this term yet, so
let's hold off on that.
What I'm going to do now is to
take a look at this potential
and expand it around the
equilibrium separation just
with an empirical collection
of terms.
But from the shape of this well,
we can see why the bond
length should increase
as the energy of
the atomic pair increases.
At absolute zero, the separation
will be this
equilibrium separation,
d zero.
But as you increase the
temperature and pump
vibrational energy into this
pair of atoms, they will get a
certain increase in energy.
And as a result, the pair will
be able to vibrate between
these two limits.
Put in some more thermal
energy by raising the
temperature, and the pair will
be able to vibrate between
these limits--
larger limits.
And so the average position of
the atom, the separation of
the atoms, is something that
is going to increase with
increasing temperature.
And that is purely a consequence
of the asymmetry
in this potential well.
If this were a Coulombic bond,
we know exactly how to model
the attractive part.
The repulsive part is a little
harder to model because that
is something that's inherently
quantum mechanical.
As the ion pair gets close
together, the electrons start
to perturb each other's
orbitals.
And a very common thing to do
is to model this as 1 over d
to the sum power n.
And n is typically on the
order of 8 to 12.
So this is something that rises
very, very steeply.
I was once at the Gordon
conference where a fist fight
almost broke out because
somebody was giving a
presentation and started from
the beginning by introducing
this model to the
potential well.
And he says, "As usual, we'll
write this as a power law, 1
over d to the n." And somebody
in a front row jumped up and
said, "what do you
mean usually?
Sensible people use
exponentials." And the speaker
said, "No, I'm going to use
a power law." That's dumb.
Exponentials work better.
Power laws, exponentials, power
laws, exponentials.
But in point of fact they're
both grossly empirical and one
is not better than the other.
The algebra changes a little
bit, but people get very, very
emotionally attached to
their physical models.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
law in the exponential.
PROFESSOR: Good, you should've
been there to
break up the fight.
If you'd gotten between them,
you'd have been likely punched
in the nose.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK so I'm going to use the power
law because as we've
seen they're the same thing
as exponentials.
So now what I'm going to do
is expand this in a purely
empirical way--
measuring distance from the
minimum of the potential well.
So what I'm going to say is
that the potential as a
function of x-- and now I won't
call it d because I'm
going to measure distance, x,
from the minimum in this well.
I'm going to say V is
a function of x.
There is a well in which the--
which keeps the atoms
separate.
I'll assume that is a parabolic
potential well, so
it'll go as first some constant
c times x squared.
Then the thing that
causes thermal
expansion is the asymmetry.
And I want the asymmetry to
increase the energy more
rapidly on the side of negative
x than on the side of
positive x.
So I'll put in a term,
g x cubed.
And I put a negative sign in
here because I want it to go
up as x becomes negative.
That means the ion pairs are
decreasing at separation.
And finally, a very fine touch,
if x becomes very
large, the potential
well should soften.
The edges of this are starting
to level out and get lower
than the purely parabolic part
for very large separations.
So that's what I'll use
as a very simple
model for my potential.
This is what gives the
asymmetry, and this is what
gives softening.
And now I'm going to ask, what
is the average value of x?
The probability of finding a
particular x is going to be
proportional to e to the
minus V of x over kt.
So I can say that the average
value of x is going to be the
integral from minus infinity to
plus infinity of the value
that I'm trying to find the
average of, namely x times the
probability of finding that x.
And that's going to e to the
minus V of x over kt.
And I will integrate
that over x.
And then I will normalize by a
term which is the integral of
the probability from minus
infinity to plus infinity of e
to the minus V of x over kt.
So that's a general expression
for an average.
It's the thing you want to
average times the probability
of finding the particular value
divided by the integral
of the probabilities.
OK now let me do some very
straightforward things and I'm
just going to rattle these
off very quickly.
We'll expand this in terms
of a series of terms.
And I'm going to expand both the
numerator and denominator
using the approximation that
e to the u is approximately
equal to 1 plus u.
So the numerator--
x times e to the minus
cx squared over kt.
I'm going to take the higher
order terms and say that e to
the gx cubed over kt times
e to the minus--
this is a minus sign
out in front--
times e to the fx fourth over
kt, can be approximated by,
since these are very, very small
terms, 1 plus g x cubed
over kt times 1 plus
fx fourth over kt.
So that's going to be, if I
put an x e to the minus cx
squared, I'm going to have a
term 1 plus g x cubed over kt,
plus f x fourth over kt.
And then a very, very minuscule
term, f times g
times x to the 7th over kt.
And I'm going to
throw that out.
If I look at these integrals
one at a time, the integral
from minus infinity to plus
infinity of x e to the minus
cx squared over k t, that's
the first term in
expansion, times dx.
That's going to be zero.
Because for positive x,
the thing that we're
integrating is plus.
For negative x, the thing that
we're integrating has the same
exponential but has
a minus sign.
So that integral is zero.
So the next term I want
to look at is x times
gx cubed over kt.
And for this I turned to my
handy book of integrals.
The integral from zero to
infinity of x to the 2n, where
that quantity is even, times e
to the minus a x squared dx,
is equal to, as you all know, 1
times 3 times 5 all the way
up to 2n minus 1 divided by 2 to
the n plus 1 times a to the
n times the square root
of pi over a.
And proof of that the integral
is left as an exercise to the
reckless student.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The x cubed
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's why
this is a 2n here.
So I can say that the x cubed
term is--but we don't have an
x cubed term.
The next term is going to
be equal to x fourth.
And this I'm going to
drop because that's
going to be x fifth.
So the integral from minus
infinity to plus infinity of x
to the fourth power times g over
kt times e to the minus
cx squared over kt dx.
If I use this formula,
turns out to be a
very, very simple thing.
It turns out to be 3/4 times the
square root of pi times g
times kt over c to the 5/2.
And kt is to the power 3/2.
So that is--
if I throw away the term in x
times x fourth which is odd,
that will vanish and I've then
thrown out only a really large
term in x to the 7th.
For the denominator, the
integral that is there before
us is the integral from minus
infinity to plus infinity of e
to the minus cx squared
over kt times 1 plus g
x cubed over kt.
This thing is going to vanish
because x is odd.
And then I'll have plus
fx fourth over kt.
That will not vanish but it's
going to be a relatively small
term, so I'll go like that.
Which means I just
have to integrate
this Gaussian factor.
And that turns out to be equal
to 2 times 1/2 times square
root of pi kT pi
times T over c.
So this is the denominator.
And if I take the ratio of those
two integrals, I have
that the average value of x will
be equal to 3/4 square
root of pi times g times kt to
the 3/2 over c to the 5/2,
divided by the square root
of pi times kt over c
to the power 1/2.
And if I carry through the
algebra correctly, this turns
out to be 3/4 of g over
c squared times kt.
So there is the average distance
between this pair of
atoms as a function of
temperature in terms of
characteristics of
the potential.
The first thing that is very
gratifying is that the bond
length, according to the simple
model, should increase
linearly with temperature.
So it tells us we would expect
things to expand linearly with
temperature which corresponds
to reality.
The next thing we'll see is that
the amount of expansion
goes inversely as the square.
That's a strong dependence--
inversely as the square of the
parabolic part of our potential.
That was the c-- c was the
coefficient in front of cx
squared in our potential.
So the stronger the bond, the
smaller the thermal expansion
coefficient is in proportion
to the reciprocal of the
square of that term.
And then finally, the last
important term to survive is
g, the asymmetry.
And the thermal expansion
coefficient should increase
with the first power of the
term that describes the
asymmetry of the
potential well.
So your intuition would
tell you that
that's the way the thermal--
linear thermal expansion
coefficient should vary.
The interesting thing is that
it depends more strongly on
the parameter that gives the
parabolic part of the
potential well.
And secondly, that it does
predict a thermal expansion
coefficient that increases--
the separation that
increases with--
in proportion to temperature.
And therefore there is a
constant linear thermal
expansion coefficient.
Now all this is true at
elevated temperatures.
At low temperatures,
thermodynamics kicks in.
And it turns out that the
linear thermal expansion
coefficient, as does energies of
vibrating atoms, must go to
zero as temperature approaches
absolute zero.
So a typical variation of the
thermal expansion coefficient
with temperature is something
that does this.
The same way as-- the same sort
of variation as things
like heat capacity.
And this temperature in here is
on the order of the Debye
temperature of the particular
material.
All right, so much for linear
thermal expansion.
And I would now like to turn
to something much more
interesting.
And that is physical properties
that involve
property tensors of rank
higher than two.
One of the important and more
interesting of these is a
property called
piezoelectricity.
Piezo means pressure, so the
property literally means
pressure electricity or pressure
induced charge.
Now what is the charge?
First of all, this does not
describe a property where-- if
I were to pick up a chunk of
crystal, and I drop it because
I just got an electric charge.
These are not mobile charges,
these are bound charges.
And the reason for the induced
charge is the fact that we are
squeezing or stretching an ionic
material, and that's
moving charged ions around.
So what we're going to do if
that process involves motion
of charged ions is to induce a
dipole moment per unit volume.
I have a little primer on some
quantities in electromagnetic
theory and I--
I brought them with me upstairs
to look them over and
I forgot to bring them down.
But I don't think we'll
need them in what's
left of this hour.
So let me say that for matter
and bulk, the quantity that is
involved in piezoelectricity
is the polarization.
And polarization is dipole
moment per unit volume.
And a dipole moment, to refresh
your memory, is that
if I have a positive charge
plus q and negative charge
minus q separated by
a distance, d.
The dipole moment, which I'll
indicate by a lowercase p, has
a vector quality and it's equal
to the magnitude of one
of these charges times the
distance between them.
And we'll define the distance
as going from the positive
charge to the negative charge.
That's a crazy way of defining a
pair of charges of equal but
opposite sign.
The reason for defining a
quantity like the dipole
moment is that this combination
of charge and
separation of the charges
comes up in all sorts of
problems in electrostatics
and electrodynamics.
And this is the delight
of people who
teach elementary physics.
You are given, on the first
quiz, a question that says--
calculate the electric field
that is created by a set of
dipoles on the Great Court
which spell out MIT.
And we can come up with all
sorts of crazy configurations
of dipoles and then calculate
the field that they produce.
And the field turns out to be
something that always involves
the product of charge and
separation in a vector sense.
Probably the best illustration
of this would be if I have a
dipole charge plus q, charge
minus q, separated by d.
And I put it in the
electric field.
The electric field, which is
defined as the force per unit
charge on a positive charge is
going to pull the positive
charge this way.
And it's going to pull the
negative charge this way.
And what that's going
to do is to place a
torque on the dipole.
And that torque is going to be
equal to a vector product of
the electric field
and a vector.
You can express it in terms of
the separation of charges
defined in a vector sense going
from the positive charge
to the negative charge.
So there's an example of how
the torque on a dipole
directly involves the product
of charge and the separation
between them and the
angle between the
field and the dipole.
So it's a useful quality and,
without further apology, we
will use it in our discussion.
Now polarization--
dipole moment per unit volume--
is just going to be
the dipole moment of one dipole
pair times the number
of them per unit volume.
And that will be a macroscopic
measure of polarization.
OK, if we subject a piece of
material that contains ions to
a stress- so here is a stress
tensor, sigma ij.
Let me call it jk.
We will create reorientation
of the dipoles.
We will have a polarization, a
dipole moment per unit volume.
This will be a vector because
there will be some net dipole
moment per unit volume.
And that will just be the sum
of all the little individual
dipole moments on the ions--
ion pairs.
And if the stress is not too
large, every component of
polarization is going to be
given by a linear combination
of every one of the components
of stress.
So we will have an array of
coefficients, d ijk The i goes
with the P and the
j and k goes with
the elements of stress.
This is something that's
called the direct
piezoelectric effect.
It's the basis of a lot
of every day devices--
pick ups on the old records
which nobody uses anymore,
cigarette lighter which nobody
uses anymore because
everybody's quit smoking--
but worked the cigarette
lighter, in some of the more
modern incarnations of
the lighter, was the
piezoelectric effect.
It's important to note that the
charges that are involved
in the piezoelectric effect
are bound charges.
Again you can't get a shock
by picking up a piece of a
strongly piezoelectric
material like quartz.
Might say then, well if there's
no spark, how could a
piezoelectric material in a
cigarette lighter cause the
lighter fuel to ignite.
The charge doesn't move.
How could there be a spark?
How could the lighter
fluid be ignited?
Anybody got an idea?
Charge can induce current flow
in circuit elements that are
removed from the charge.
So if you have a little
capacitor in the lighter that
is near the piezoelectric
element that will develop the
charge, you can induce current
flow in a circuit as a result
of that capacitor experiencing
the electric charge of the
piezoelectric induced charge.
And that's how the little
piezoelectric cigarette
lighters worked.
OK, this stress--
array of stress elements, nine
of them, constitutes a tensor
of second rank.
Polarization is a vector
per unit volume.
This is a tensor
of first rank.
of second rank.
Therefore it follows that this
array of coefficients, d ijk
will be three equations
involving all
nine elements of stress.
So it'll be a total of 27
coefficients in the array.
And this array constitutes a
tensor of the third rank.
So this is clearly a property
tensor which relates a
generalized force--
the stress tensor to a
generalized displacement,
which is the dipole moment
per unit volume.
Since this is a property of
a crystal, that tensor is
subject to symmetry
restrictions.
In particular, if there is some
direction, cosine scheme
Cij, that corresponds to the
operation of a symmetry
element, then it follows that if
we evaluate the new tensor
elements, d ijk prime in terms
of the old elements, that is
going to be a transformation
of the form Cil, Cjm, Ckn
times all 27 of the original
tensor elements, d lmn.
And the l, m, and n are dummy
indices, just as with our
second rank tensors.
And the ijk are real indices
that go with the subscripts on
the particular tensor element.
So there are 27 coefficients.
And each transformed element is
going to be a sum therefore
of 27 coefficients times--
each times three direction
cosines.
So each transform tensor element
is going to be given
by a sum of 3 times
27 quantities.
And to do the complete
transformation would involve
doing it 27 times.
So 3 times 27 squared is the
number of terms that we're
going to have to write down to
transform the entire tensor.
Not a terribly encouraging
prospect unless you use the
method of direct inspection,
namely that the tensor
transforms like the product of
the corresponding coordinates.
And then it works fairly
quickly, particularly for
symmetry transformations, where
there are a lot of zeros
in the direction
cosine scheme.
So we're going to have to do
this for each of the crystal--
crystal point groups.
So we're going to have to do
this exercise of 3 times 27
times 27 times the 32 point
groups that exist, which
becomes an even more
daunting task.
But let's do one such
transformation and let me show
you that it, in fact, it's going
to go fairly easily.
So let me follow the tracks of
what we did with second rank
tensors and examine the
restrictions imposed by inversion.
OK so the transformation of
the axes, as we've seen
before, that's produced
by 1 bar.
That's going to take
x1 and change its
direction to minus x1.
It's going to take x2 and change
its sense to an x2
prime that points in
this direction.
And take x3 and change its
sense to something
that points down here.
So that's x3 prime.
So the relation between the
axes, before and after
inversion, is that x1
prime equals x1--
minus x1--
x2 prime is equal to minus x2.
And x3 prime is equal
to minus x3.
And we've seen this before.
It's deja vu all over again.
So Cij, the direction cosine
scheme, is equal
to minus 1, 0, 0.
0, minus 1, 0.
0, 0, minus 1.
So let's transform a
representative tensor element
for a change of axes that
corresponds to that direction
cosine scheme.
And that's the same as
physically inverting the
crystal and demanding that the
property be unchanged if that
is a symmetry transformation
which
leaves the crystal invariant.
So if we look at some d ijk
prime, that's going to be Cil,
Cjm, Ckn, d lmn, where this is
a sum over the index l, the
dummy index m, and the double
index n, from 1 to 3.
If we sum over Ci something, the
only term of the form Ci
something, regardless of what
i is, is going to be the
diagonal term Cii, the diagonal
direction cosine Cii.
In other words, if i were 1, the
only term of the form C1
something that is non-zero,
is C11.
If I sum over m, the only term
that is non-zero is C, with m
equal to j.
So this is going to be Cjj.
And if I sum over n, the
only term that is going
to be left is Ckk.
And all this will be
times d ijk, the
single tensor element.
Regardless of the values of i,
j, and k, they are all equal
to minus 1.
So the operation then of
inversion, then says that for
the transformed crystal, d ijk
prime for any i, j, and k, is
going to be equal
to minus d ijk.
But if this is a symmetry
transformation, the tensor
element has to be the same
before and after.
And the only number which can
be equal to the negative of
itself is zero.
So we have, with
one swell foop,
transformed 27th tensor elements--
each one of them a sum
of 27 elements in
the original tensor.
So the conclusion is, if a
crystal has the operation of
inversion, all d ijk vanish.
What does that mean?
Means the property just
doesn't exist.
So no crystal which has an
inversion center can display
piezoelectricity.
Which means that none of the
11 Laue groups can be
piezoelectric.
And the only point groups
for crystals that can be
piezoelectric are the 32
minus 11 equals 21--
and this isn't even one
of my good days--
acentric point groups--
the noncentrosymmetric
point groups.
And, these, in principle,
can be all different.
So we can't get away with just
looking at the restrictions of
Laue groups as we did with
second rank tensors.
We're going to have to look at
every one of the point groups
that have no inversion center.
And these can, in principle,
be different, and
they usually are.
Let me give you a physically--
physical feeling for why the
piezoelectric effect cannot
exist for a crystal that has
an inversion center in it.
Let's suppose we cut a wafer
from our single crystal,
regardless of orientation.
And we subject it to a
compressive stress.
We will see--
and I've got a primer on some
simple electrostatics that may
be useful--
that a polarization in the x1
direction manifests itself as
a charge per unit area on the
surface and an opposite charge
on the other surface.
So P1 corresponds, numerically
and physically, to a charge
per unit area on a surface
that's normal to x1.
OK now let's suppose that that
crystal has an inversion
center in it.
And that means we should be able
to invert the crystal and
measure exactly the same
charge per unit area.
Well, if this is surface a, and
this is surface b, we can
imagine ourselves doing the
thought experiment in which we
invert the crystal.
So this surface becomes b and
this surface becomes a.
And we apply the same
sigma along x1--
a compressive stress.
It's really doing exactly the
same thing that we were doing
before-- inverting
the crystal.
And now we say that the property
has to stay the same.
So now we are demanding that
surface b have a positive
charge per unit area, and
surface a develop a negative
charge per unit area--
completely the reverse of
what happened here.
But yet what we're doing is
just squeezing the plate.
The crystal can't tell
which side is up,
which side is down.
We're applying the same
compressive effect.
So these two distributions of
charge are not the same and
can be the same only if
that charge is zero.
So physically we can see why
the crystal can't be
piezoelectric.
If you don't like to invert
the crystal--
if you can't do that
physically--
one thing we can do is leave the
crystal alone and invert
the compressive stress.
So this is sigma top and this
is sigma bottom which is
exactly equal to it but
opposite in direction.
If we invert the stress
relative--
relative to the crystal--
then what we've done is
to take sigma top--
leave the crystal alone--
so this is now the sigma that
was squishing the top.
Here's the sigma that was
squishing the bottom and well,
that's clearly doing
the same thing.
So inverting the stress,
relative to the crystal, is
the same as inverting
the crystal
relative to the stress.
And nothing is supposed to
happen but clearly the sign of
the charge is going
to be reversed.
So that just won't work.
The charge has to disappear.
OK this is the direct
piezoelectric effect.
It can exist only for crystals
that lack an inversion center.
Let me mention some other
piezoelectric effects.
So we mentioned that a
polarization, given by a third
rank tensor times an applied
stress, sigma ij, is the
direct piezoelectric
photoelectric effect.
However, if we have a stress,
we also have a strain.
So another piezoelectric effect,
which is not dignified
with a name, is that we can
apply a stress that creates a
given state of strain.
And we again, we'll get a
polarization per unit--
a charge per unit area
of polarization.
And this is a set of
coefficients which are
represented by e.
And we can write a tensor
relation of this sort-- that
components of polarization,
charge per unit area, normal
to axis xi, is given by a linear
combination of every
one of the components
of strain.
This is something that is not
dignified by any name.
And clearly, the piezoelectric
coefficients, e, have to be
related to the piezoelectric
coefficients, d, by the
elastic constant somehow--
unless we are doing
the same thing.
We've got to create a stress,
operationally, in order to
create the strain.
So a stress creates a strain.
And that has to describe the
same polarization if we've
done the same thing.
So the e's and the d's
have to be related.
Another piezoelectric effect
involves a applying an
electric field.
And if we apply an electric
field, we will in general
create a strain.
This direct piezoelectric effect
is three equations that
involve a linear combination
of nine elements of stress.
This piezoelectric relation
here is going to involve
writing an equation for each
of nine elements of strain.
And there would be three
components of the electric
field vector.
So it'll be three this way.
So both of these relations
involve 27 elements.
So again we're going to have a
third rank tensor because the
electric field is a vector--
strain is a tensor.
And now the mind boggling thing
that I will leave you
with is exactly the same set of
coefficients, d ij describe
both effects.
And this effect is given
a special name.
This is called the converse
piezoelectric effect.
And it's not at all clear how
strain, in terms of electric
field, should be described in
terms of the same array of 27
numbers as polarization
per unit
volume in terms of stress.
And that is an argument that
is based on thermodynamics.
So that's a good
place to quit.
We'll have some fun in looking
at a few symmetry restrictions
imposed on the acentric point
groups, 21 of them.
We're not going to do all 21.
If you know how to do one or
two, and marvel over the
results, you can do them all.
But one thing that we'll be
asking is how can we represent
the variation of the
piezoelectric effect with
orientation of the crystal.
And the answer is we can't.
We can't.
Because what is the direction
of what we're doing?
There are nine elements of
stress, not just three
components of a vector which
defines an orientation.
There are nine parameters
here.
And there are three components
to the charge per unit area--
that's a vector.
So all that one can do for these
higher ranked tensors is
to look for a special,
generalized force.
And then perhaps for a very
special form of that
generalized force, that tensor,
look at how the
polarization changes.
But you're going to have to
look at six different
representation surfaces--
each one which will describe
a different
piezoelectric effect.
So this will become less simple
in many respects.
But correspondingly, more
interesting because we'll have
some really wild, mind boggling
representation
surfaces for piezoelectric
effects.
OK so we'll stop there and
resume on Thursday.
And I'll let you get back to
the MRS if that's where you
earlier today.